hey guys Pete here this will be my sir
see how long may she reign video it will
contain spoilers for everything up to
this point in both the books and through
season six in the show if you're not
up-to-date you will not want to watch
this video unless for some reason you
just don't like surprises Queen Cersei
Lannister first of her name queen of the
Andals and the first men protector of
the Seven Kingdoms long may she reign
long may she reign but how long will she
reign and what exactly is she packing
now that she has gone from ruling behind
the scenes to being cut off from her
power and confined to the red key to
finally just taking over altogether as
the presumptive boss of the realm before
we get started I just want to make a
couple quick disclaimers one I'm a big
fan of TV show Circe's character
portrayal in a drama of this scale is so
many rich characters she has a way of
making everything she's in memorable
number two I don't think any of what's
going on with sho Cersei at the end of
season 6 will actually happen in the
books even though she's pretty much in
the same place after Dance with Dragons
waiting for trial it is way less likely
that her path out is a path to power
we'll have to wait and see but as far as
I'm concerned Queen Cersei the first on
the show it has a completely different
story than book Cersei from here on out
in this video we're going to look at
what a Queen Cersei Rea might look like
and how long she is likely to stay on
the throne most would be speculation
based on the events that led up to her
taking control and the relative strength
behind her compared to the other
factions who want to claim the throne so
quickly let's look at what how he got to
where we are
Cersei is the oldest child of Tywin and
Joanna Lannister she has a twin Jaime
who was born shortly after her and a
younger brother Tyrion while giving
birth to Tyrion Joanna Lannister died
her father was a very powerful dude he
was his Lord of Casterly Rock in the
hand of the last Targaryen King Aerys
the second he was considered to be a
great hand and held the position for 20
years things were strained between Tywin
and the Mad King though and two major
events led to him stepping down as hand
first time and wanted to marry Cersei to
Eris's heir Rhaegar the King refused
this match and instead Rhaegar married
Elia Martell of Dorne as a side note
here Prince Rhaegar also ran off with
Lyanna Stark who was betrothed to Robert
Baratheon Rhaegar and Lyanna produced a
child Jon Snow to make matters worse
Aerys
named Jamie Lannister to his king guard
at age 15 which took away Tywin's heir
to Casterly Rock since the king you know
the Kingsguard can't marry Cersei played
a secret role in Jaime's decision to
join the Kingsguard as the two twin
lovers hoped that this would keep them
close together Tywin eventually resigned
his hand of the king and Robert's
rebellion then broke out the Lannisters
mostly stay out of things during the
rebellion but played a pivotal role in
the sacking of King's Landing after the
momentum shifted in the Baratheon's
direction
Robert claimed the throne and married
Cersei who continued her incestuous
relationship with her brother while
married to Robert Cersei gave birth to
three children Joffrey Marcella and
Tommen Joffrey became the crown prince
but his readers and viewers we know that
Jaime is the father instead of Robert
which makes him a legitimate Robert's
and Jon Arryn discovered that the
children were actually Jaime's bastards
so Cersei set a plan in motion to have
him killed Robert then installed Ned
Stark his hand and Cersei decided to
move on Robert staging a hunting
accident where he was fatally wounded
this set the stage for Cersei to install
Joffrey before his little legitimacy
could be questioned get rid of Ned Stark
who knew her secret and put her in
control while her father Tywin was off
fighting in the war of the five kings
unfortunately King Joffrey was the first
was murdered on his wedding day by his
bride-to-be's family due to his sadistic
nature and not so luring disposition
this put Circe's youngest son Tommen on
the throne and along with her brother
Tyrion killing her father made Cersei
the behind-the-scenes ruler of the realm
at the height of her power she made
moves against her enemies by reinstating
the faith militant which eventually
backfired and landed her in the dungeons
she was facing trial for a number of
charges including treason and regicide
to get out of it she confessed her
crimes and is forced to do a walk of
shame naked through King's Landing but
at that same time she gets to go back to
the red key to await trial this is where
the the book storyline is paused until
the next book comes out and the TV show
continues on which I just don't think
they're gonna be the same
you know Cersei is definitely shamed in
the books she doesn't have the same kind
of bounce back so we'll just have to see
what happens Cersei is dealt a blow on
the TV show when the Sparrow uses his
influence to have King Tom and ban trial
combat in the seven kingdoms up to this
point she has been confident that her
champion the Cogburn rebooted mountain
can't be defeated which would mean that
the gods can't find her guilty of her
crimes
banning trial by combat leaves Cersei
with few option options so she decides
destroying the great Sept of Baelor with
wildfire is probably the best way of
getting out at having to face justice in
this process she kills the high Sparrow
her son's wife Queen Margaery her uncle
and handed the King Kevin Lannister and
Marjorie's father mace Tyrell the Lord
of Highgarden she also has grand maester
pycelle knocked off which clears out all
of the remaining resistance against her
in the small council so everything is
going good until Tommen decides that
what has happened was too much for him
and he decides to take a swan dive out
his window this leads to the final
King's Landing scene of season six where
we see Cersei get crowned the first
queen of Westeros but seriously how is
this even possible and will she be able
to keep all this power now that she has
it to speculate on how good sir sees
chances of retaining the throne are
let's look at how at who she has behind
her and what she's up against since the
show showed her coronation and that she
got rid of her closest enemies we're
gonna assume that she for the time being
is unopposed and undisputed inside the
walls of King's Landing we saw that
Qyburn was wearing the hint of the Kings
pin when he presented her with the crown
and the Zambia Mountain appears to be
the Lord Commander of her Kingsguard
Jamie doesn't seem to be enthusiastic
about the turn of events but we will
also assume that he is behind her with a
loyal on what the loyal Lannister army
remember in the show that their
relationship is still going strong
and you know even though it isn't in the
books it doesn't seem like that's gonna
change like right away a quick glance of
the show's version of the Lannister
family tree gives us an idea of just who
might be able to oppose her inside her
own family as you can see everyone is
pretty much died except Cersei and her
two brothers the only other living
relative is Kevin's wife Donna Swift
Donna has never really shown any
interest in being a part of like the
day-to-day ongoing stuff that happens in
King's Landing or like going after any
power at all so I don't think that she's
gonna be a problem in the books Tywin
has more siblings but as far as the show
is concerned it seems like Cersei only
has to worry about her brothers Jaime
would actually be the more obvious
successor
up from the family since he was
removed from the Kingsguard and he's
male but I'm not gonna go down any
rabbit holes based on what would be the
sense of a line of succession the show
keeps the popular characters in the
center of the story even when it doesn't
make perfect sense so like I said before
we'll just roll with things how they are
so we'll say that the Lannister army is
behind her plus the city watch and
assume she can raise a medium-sized army
from the Crown lands what about the rest
of Westeros whether Cersei is sitting on
the Iron Throne or not she has major
problems one of them is Daenerys who has
departed Dragon Bay which used to be
called slavers Bay and is gonna be
heading up to Narrow Sea another problem
is that she took the throne by force and
killed some important members of other
great houses in the process
who exactly is on Cersei side well her
inner circle consists of Qyburn Jaime
and the zombie mountain
Qyburn has no ties to anyone that we
know of and his maester Shane was
revoked by the Citadel since she killed
pycelle they should actually send a new
grand maester from Old Town but who even
knows what they will do in light of his
sudden disappearance Jaime can command
the Lannister army and work with the
other allies that we have seen from his
recent trip to the lip to the Riverland
it is an absolutely clear Holly where
you act to everything that's happening
King's Landing while he was gone though
so like we may find him in some tough
you know situations now that Cersei has
lost all of her children her love for
her children has been her one redeeming
quality and the thing that's kept her
kept her like somewhat under control
and now that they are gone she should
officially be off the rails zombie mom
is basically a killing machine who seems
more than capable of protecting the
queen of the rest of the great houses
and kingdoms that the Lannisters can
count on we have well we had the
Riverlands Walder Frey might be gone -
might be gone but the Tully's are pretty
much neutralized on the show as well
the remaining phrase have no reason not
to support the crown regardless of who
succeeds Walder so you know that's just
a given I think and the books Lady
Stoneheart is wreaking havoc in the
Riverlands with the Brotherhood without
banners but in the show they seem to be
going north and there is no lady store
stone-hard based on the recent events
with the Tyrells and that the Bolton's
had been defeated in the north none of
the other regions or great houses can
really be counted on half of the
Greyjoy's are with Dany which leaves
Euron and his half of the Iron Men but I
kind of expect them and like to end up
with Daenerys since he mentioned his
plan was to go off and marry her book
you're on is totally different so we
can't really know for sure but we don't
have any strong evidence to put them on
the side of the crown to just put
together some rough numbers we can give
the throne fifty thousand Lannister
soldiers two thousand gold cloaks from
the city watch maybe around fifteen
thousand troops from the crown lands and
forty five thousand soldiers from the
Riverlands that would come up with a
total of one hundred and twelve thousand
give or take Daenerys is definitely on
her way to Westeros to claim the throne
this is what a lot of fans have been
waiting for since to be very beginning
and it's finally upon us let's look at
how her her forces stack up against the
crown her and her inner circle consists
of Tyrion grey worm and Varys Tyrion is
her hand and he as a wealth of knowledge
that will be helpful he understands his
sister Cersei and her motivations has
intimate understanding of how King's
Landing operates from his time is hand
to King Joffrey and he knows about the
vast network of tunnels underneath the
city grey worm is a leader of the
unsullied army and he is absolutely
loyal he could be useful in a number of
different situations Varys storyline is
in the show it's totally different than
the one in the books but he appears to
be wholeheartedly behind Daenerys and he
brings a lot to the table his connection
and his connections in King's Landing
are unrivaled from his time as master of
whisperers it's also thought that part
of caverns power comes from his running
the little birds which they you know
they started out on beerus aside so they
could easily be swayed back in that
direction for someone who's never lived
in Westeros Daenerys has quite a bit of
support there not to mention she has
picked up some real military might in
the preparation for her invasion we know
that Danny is bringing her in solid and
the Dothraki she also has Daario and the
cell swords but it isn't clear how many
were staying in marine or still are
hired by her so we won't really focus on
them yar on Theon Greyjoy had pledged
their men and ships and Varys has
brought in Dorne and the reach with you
know I don't know sure what the sand
snakes call their house was house
Martell but they wiped it out and so you
know we have them in house Tyrell will
look at the North separately in a minute
because we can't really say how they're
gonna get involved but if we look at the
numbers of who we know
Danny has she has 8,000 unsullied about
50,000 mounted Dothraki 10,000 Ironborn
maybe 30,000 Dornish and for simplicity
we'll say 50,000 soldiers from the
Tyrells in the reach I say you know
simplicity because according to the
books the forces from the reach are a
lot higher but it seems like on the show
they do it a little bit different like I
know they mentioned that the Lannister
army was the biggest army so we'll just
add the numbers that those numbers
together and that would come up to about
a hundred and forty eight thousand that
is the tale of the tape for where we are
in the end of season six in part two of
this video series I will talk about the
north the intangibles like Danny's
dragons and my predictions on how
Circe's time on the throne will play out
make sure you subscribe to my channel so
that you'll know when part two comes out
in a few days please like the video and
leave any questions you have in the
comment section maybe I will use some of
them when I'm putting the finishing
touches on part two also check out my
jon snow dragon rider theory video which
I'll put a link right up at the top for
and let me know how you think that will
fit into the story thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you soon